[Musique]
ce combat
c'est la plus cosmopolite des villes
d'espagne
17 millions de touristes passent chaque
année à barcelone
et certains décident de ne plus la
quitter
c'est le cas de zhao arrivé ici il ya
six ans il fait aujourd'hui découvrir la
cité catalane à ciel ouvert
c'est une ville raffiné où les gens
aiment faire la fête
mais cette année zhao vise un tout
nouveau marché
celui des visites en minibus
romain lui est d'origine toulousaine
avec oscar ils cuisinent à barcelone
depuis 16 ans avec la même passion et un
certain succès
[Applaudissements]
mais dans quelques mois un défi l'attend
il ouvre un bistrot dans l'un des
quartiers les plus touristiques de la
ville
hyper rare s'est imposé d'avoir un long
mois on a dû
edwards et salvatore sont des
barcelonais pure souche
depuis des générations
il défie les lois de la pesanteur
on a réussi cette figure que trois fois
dans le passé trois fois seulement en 45
ans
ils vont vivre l'une des plus belles
journées de leur histoire
[Musique]
emmanuel vient de lille
voilà à barcelone il crée toutes sortes
de meubles à partir de palettes recycler
d'anciens pompiers
[Musique]
mais sa passion c'est sa rue on va aller
voir les décorations de la rue verdi
tous les ans avec ses voisins on se
démène pour en faire la plus belle rue
du quartier
enfin la sagrada familia
c'est la star de barcelone
3 millions d'entrées par an
c'est aussi le plus vieux chantier du
monde
jordi fauli l'héritier de gaudi nous
entraîne dans ses coulisses
ce lieu peut accueillir le score de 600
personnes qui chantera des cantiques
pendant la messe saleté gauche
la vi e
jordi et ses tailleurs de pierre
trois mois pour terminer les
inscriptions de la façade sud chaque
lettre est ce plus d'une tonne
pendant un an ils nous font découvrir
cette ville qui ne dort jamais ses
secrets et ses coutumes
romain fornell est un jeune chef
toulousain
je vais me servir
il vit à barcelone depuis 16 ans et on
connaît toutes les traditions culinaires
etc enquête en france et c'est un beau
couple et bautista dans le sable donc
ceux qui font ce qu'ils font ici
il est il aimait tant a égorgé
il y met à dégorger et y'a pas un pet de
sable blanc tu peut les manger
ce matin romain n'est pas venu au marché
uniquement pour faire ses courses
il a un rendez vous d'affaires
avec oscar son ami catalan
est un endroit le sandwich
sandwich un très très bon mais pas un
petit local qu'on a dans un bocal c'est
très très difficile à prouver
cet ancien entrepôt d'un volaille et
vous aujourd'hui une fortune
l'espace et les hyper rare s'est imposé
d'avoir un long mois on a dû parlementer
réguler cet étrange de l'espace en effet
l'espace au dessus
l'ouverture du bistrot est prévue dans
trois mois l'emplacement est idéal car
la boqueria est le marché le plus
touristique de barcelone
c'est ici que robben revient chercher
l'inspiration pour ses multiples risques
[Musique]
c'est le seul à en espagne
avoir joué la carte française il n'y a
pas d'autres chefs français en espagne
qui ont qui soit un taux michelin qui
ont plusieurs gammes de restaurants
comme comme nous on en a su monter
romain est arrivé à barcelone à 19 ans à
24 il y obtient une étoile michelin
a fait 14 ans que je me rassure et me
dit oh oui ça sympa
sauf à ce problème c'est
aujourd'hui le cas et lisse et son
restaurant fars
mélina caelis très bien l'école forme
après avoir été simple chef romain est
aujourd'hui le propriétaire de la faire
oui l'équipe victor
victor qu'est le chef des ago qui vient
de portugal
pâtissier sommelier commis tu rajoutes
pour la drees a suffi à la brigade du
cac et lisse en compte quinze employés
et une équipe de consultants triés sur
le volet
j'aime à nancy champion olympique de
water polo fait c'est ce qu'ils disent
est passé c'est vrai après à côté vous
le connaissez peut-être c'est un petit
joueur de
demandes
et qu'on sait qui est la pièce maîtresse
c'est grâce à lui que je suis à voir
seulement deux séances à lui que quand
on est autour de la table aujourd'hui
voilà
la sésamie là une fois par semaine on
fait un repas un goûter les nouveaux
plats sains et me donnent leur avis me
critique mais ça permet d'alterner le
goal tac
je reste selon nikola karabatic
chantôme nude en dalles
donne un coup de main pour précis le
canard en sang
son célibat
romain s'accorde une pause entre amis
car demain un défi l'attend il reçoit à
dîner 120 chefs c'est devenu l'un
[Rires]
des défis depuis qu'il est arrivé du
portugal il y a 6 ans john on a relevé
d'autre
le premier consistait à faire découvrir
barcelone en side car
aujourd'hui il possède quatre salles car
d'époque entièrement rénové
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà notre flotte de moto nous sommes
une petite société car nous faisons du
sur mesure
il y a un peu tôt ce matin mais il faut
y aller parce qu'on a pas mal de réseau
aujourd'hui kim l'un des pilotes de la
compagnie est le premier pas
il a rendez vous avec un couple de
clients américains
aujourd'hui ce sera magnifique les rues
vont être recouvertes d'étaler de rose
et donc on va commencer par la rue arago
cette ville est un mot tonnes rappelle
des souvenirs de jeunesse à karine et
dennis
sinon ça me rappelle une chanson
[Musique]
dans la prochaine rue sur votre droite
vous allez pouvoir admirer des bâtiments
construits par gaudi
aujourd'hui barcelone célèbre la sant
jordi
l'équivalent de la saint valentin
pour l'occasion la célèbre avenue des
ramblas est fermée à la circulation
c'est une belle tradition
aujourd'hui on célèbre le printemps oui
c'est merveilleux ce sont plusieurs
événements c'est un festival du livre
les célébrations de la route c'est la
fête de votre sympathique
la tradition catalane veut
qu'aujourd'hui
l'amoureux du offre une rose
vous devez couper la tige quinze jours
sur la route fut rien
l'amoureuse elle doit choisir un lien
pour moi
gemma rose et il a son libre
dix minutes plus tard dennis et karine
arrive au sommet du monde jouit la plus
haute colline de la ville
la cathédrale bien tour quoi donc la
sagrada familia qui est encore en
construction
la sagrada familia
c'est le plus vieux chantier du monde
cela fait cent vingt-six ans que dix
hommes poursuivre le projet fou d'antoni
gaudi le célèbre architecte catalan
aujourd'hui c'est jordi fauli qui a pris
le relais c'est lui qui dirige les
travaux
tous les jours je passe par cette porte
et chaque fois que j'entre je ressens
une vive émotion top de mouches et au
canada chaque jour le spectacle est
différent
bien sûr fait autrement
il ya des détails que je vois sous un
autre angle
ce n'est jamais la même chose
la sagrada familia est l'unique
basilique au monde où les marteaux
piqueurs résonne huit heures par jour et
personne n'y prête attention
alors
regardez vous pouvez voir les vitraux
qui vendent de la nef
ils forment un dégradé de couleurs
[Musique]
jordi supervise la construction de la
sagrada depuis un quart de siècle
chaque jour ils descendent dans ses
sous-sols car c'est là qu'il conserve
ses trésors
dans les entrailles de la sagrada
familia se cache l'atelier des maquettes
c'est le centre névralgique de la
basilique
car gaudi n'a laissé aucun plan aucun
écrit il ne travaillait qu'avec des
modèles en trois dimensions
qu'est ce que c'est tout ça
alors ça ce sont tous les modèles
qu'utiliser gaoudi pour construire la
sagrada familia
il se basait sont des maquettes pour
édifier la basilique et elles ont toutes
été détruites pendant la guerre civile
tout ce que vous voyez là ce sont des
morceaux que nous avons retrouvé
restaurer et assemblé et qui nous
servent de documentation pour continuer
la construction
le défi quotidien de cette équipe est
gigantesque
sans elles la sagrada familia ne
pourrait pas poursuivre sa construction
qui parlez moi je vois si la maquette de
large sur lequel seront apposés les
lettres qui sont taillés en ce moment
je crois qu'ils travaillent sur cette
partie
une fois terminée ça devrait ressembler
grâce aux maquettiste
jordi respecte ses délais
ce matin il présente à la presse les
différents chantiers
comme la construction de la sagrada
dépend uniquement de fonds privés
jordi fait régulièrement la promotion de
l'avancée des travaux
larcher soutenu par huit colonnes
en avant première il présente les plans
de la plus haute tour de l'édifice
une tour qui en 2025 culminera à plus de
170 m
le lendemain
comme tous les matins depuis 16 ans
faye ou martin seront sur un chantier
hors du commun
il y à déjà de la lumière dans l'atelier
ça veut dire que les collègues se sont
levés encore plus tôt que moi allez on
va les rejoindre
beyou et le chef des tailleurs de pierre
de la sagrada familia
italienne nous allons à l'atelier c'est
un peu plus loin
voici des pierres de montjuic elles sont
typiques de barcelone c'est notre pierre
principale
celle ci vient de murcie c'est une
pierre calcaire que nous utilisons pour
l'intérieur elle a une couleur très
blanche est très agréable et là c'est un
grenier de français de la région du tarn
fenioux rejoint son équipe
pour répartir les travaux de la journée
aujourd'hui on continue de travailler
sur la salle des croisillons mais toi
emilio tu restes ici car on doit
terminer un travail sur une pierre de
montjuic
aller au boulot
et millions doit finir de sculpter une
des lettres qui en aura la façade sud de
la basilique
un bloc de pierre d'une tonne et demie
c'est le tailleur de pierre qui donne la
forme définitive de la lettre
sur ce air par exemple
on obtient une texture avec des
interstices qu'aucune machine ne peut
reproduire
dans trois mois toutes les lettres de
vont être posées sur le fronton
loin des lieux touristiques barcelone
abrite quelques quartiers typiques
à l'ouest de la ville au pied du parc
guell également créé par gaudi le
quartier de gracia et comme un village
c'est là
qu'emmanuel petit a décidé de
s'installer il ya un an et demi
moi je suis de lille je suis du nord de
la france j'ai toujours adoré adoré
l'espagne un jour j'ai proposé à
véronique de venir vivre ici pour les
pour les enfants pour nous pour pour
tous
ok
pour vivre ici emmanuel a abandonné son
métier gambie cythère
aujourd'hui il crée des meubles à partir
de palettes recyclé
là on est dans l'atelier on va aller au
fond là où il ya
le stockage
de nos palettes
pas grand-chose
ingéraient quinze jours même pas 1
afin de récupérer
les palettes sont découpées et
transformé par véronique son épouse
quelques minutes elle est capable de
table qui est un miroir
vous
quatre cents mètres plus loin tous les
objets sont exposés et vendus dans la
boutique tout et avec de la récup que ça
soit des robinet est des boîtes de
conserve
derrière son comptoir
emmanuel travaille sur un nouveau modèle
de table qu'un client vient du commander
moi je suis plus créatifs et véronique
et plus pratique mais l'un va pas sans
l'autre
à peine assemblée
à les eaux
la table est livrée en personne
grâce au bouche à oreille la plupart des
clients sont des voisins ou des
commerçants du quartier voilà la
tension pompiers
[Musique]
ouf
alors voilà on avait déjà on avait déjà
fourni une table basse avec des
roulettes industriels
et donc maintenant cette table va venir
derrière
à la place de ça
[Musique]
j'aime bien parce que c'est fait à la
main c'est rustique mais bien fini et
puis ça se marie bien avec la décoration
du magasin
[Musique]
mais un pari plus important attend
emmanuel dans douze mois il participe au
grand concours de décoration de vue de
son nouveau quartier
[Musique]
est ici
représenté sari est quelque chose de
très important
[Musique]
s'il y en a deux qui connaissent bien
barcelone et ses traditions
ce sont sales 20 élèves
dans leur quartier du peuple et nous où
ils ont grandi ils partagent la même
passion
moi je suis entré en 96 et quoi juste
après
oui plus de 15 ans c'est sûr qu'on se
connaît depuis au moins tout ce temps là
est toujours dans la même peña
oui toujours ensemble oui toujours qu'à
se tenir deux ou trois fois par semaine
on se retrouve ici et tous les dimanches
on s'entraîne
avec
les castels c'est l'une des plus
anciennes traditions catalanes
on est près de 200 à s'entraîner ici on
s'exerce pour édifier des pyramides
humaines en catalan on appelle ça des
castes et hier
ce choix c'est le dernier entraînement
avant le grand concours de la fête de la
mersey
[Musique]
des doigts à la charge de former les
jeunes
cette ceinture est vraiment très
importante elle nous sert surtout à
maintenir la colonne vertébrale bien
droite pour pouvoir supporter tous les
toits qu'il ya au dessus et en plus elle
permet aux plus petits de calais leurs
pieds derrière grimper tout en haut de
la pyramide
cette ceinture on appelle ça un la
faille chirac
près d'un tiers des castes et guerre
sont des enfants
aller 1 2 3 allez tous
maintenant mais bien ton petit fail chat
voilà c'est bien a tempéré via le site
est bien calé
plus léger ce sont eux qui constituent
les derniers étages de la pire année
voilà c'est parfait clara c'est parfait
comme ça
voilà quoi
tous les cas steyer doit obligatoirement
passer dans cette caisse
moi je prends la hauteur des épaules là
où on pose les pieds pour que la
construction soit bien équilibré quand
on fait la passe
il faut écouter attentivement ce que dit
le chef de file
très concentré
il ne faut pas faire de bon
là c'est le moment critique
[Musique]
et
à c'est lille a une petite fille de cinq
ans qui se hisse au sommet
ça fait deux ans que je m'entraîne et
quand je suis en haut je vois tout le
coût
et les arbres et puis c'est quoi
lila est la mascotte de la peña
d'anjou semaine est casté lire de
barcelone tenteront devant leur public
d'édifier la plus faible cours de leur
histoire
dans le quartier de la barceloneta l'a61
quartier des pêcheurs
romain retrouve son ami oscar qui
agrandissent
la barceloneta sans l'apport d'un
triangle clients qui s'ouvre d'un côté
il ya le cogne larroy et de l'autre
vraiment un triangle entre la mer et la
bière
ce soir romain va cuisiner pour 120
chefs dans le restaurant panoramique
d'oscar
mais avant ce défi mes deux amis
décident de prendre quelques forces
voici le restaurant on en a inventé la
fameuse bombe bas de la barceloneta
c'est une boulette de pommes de terre
fourrées à la viande que l'on fait frire
je connais très bien les propriétaires
du vieux quand j'étais gamin j'allais à
l'école avec eux
oui comment tu vas
attention bombasse
la face à vendre voilà la fameuse bombe
a servi avec une linda une sauce
piquante
soc 7 secret de la maison
ici toute la famille est tout seul
rien n'a changé ici depuis 60 ans comme
moi
ces deux quick je suis en france et le
même goût
incroyable rien n'a changé le expiré
dans les barriques en 60 ans tout est
resté à l'identique ça a toujours été
comme ça
le resteront de skarv surplombe la plage
et la ville de barcelone va
vous allez voir voilà très surprenant
c'est au dessus du téléphérique de de
barcelone
c'est un endroit qui s'appelle la
taurine altama
l'unique accès au restaurant se fait par
cet ascenseur
à
part quand il ya beaucoup de vent l'a
toujours
s'il ya un système de sécurité qui
bloque l'ascenseur un peu plus
l'utiliser on peut pas travailler pour
monter à pied c'est une ascension de 75
mn 25 et harris hausse
donc c'est là c'est la plus belle ville
barcelone le vieux port lay a crié en
bas si à gauche va crier de renvoi l'atv
des arbres toute la ville c'est un
endroit merveilleux
au sommet la vue est à 360 degrés
est et les vals vertige
il cause était juste une plateforme
oui il n'y avait pas de fenêtre alors il
a commencé à ramper
j'ai dû me mettre à genoux et ramper
pour admirer la vue très impressionnant
romain doit préparer un dîner de gala
pour 120 disciples d'escoffier
venus du monde entier
ce sont soit des chefs professionnels
des métiers de bouche soit des
producteurs de produits excellents des
producteurs de vins des producteurs
d'olives des producteurs de fromages etc
qui ont été remarquées comme étant l'
excellence
romain à 6 heures pour tout préparer
je
voilà la cuisine au cnt
c'est une cuisine et qui est entré huit
restaurants dire mais en train de
faire les derniers préparatifs
avec les une cuisine qui est qui va
faire la cuisine de bateaux
en hiver la nuit tombe vite à 18h toute
épreuve
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
avant tout est prêt
romain présente les différents plans au
maître d'hôtel
ce soir nous allons servir des classes
est
adapté aux
alleuds paladares locale
on commencera par une royal d'ur s'est
servi dans sa coquille non seulement
chanel la concha et les fuites pascal
des ratures ça ressemble un petit peu
influent ayatollah
merci bon service et profiter sur mon
père
[Applaudissements]
parmi les convives de nombreux chefs
étoilés
[Musique]
en cuisine le compte à rebours est lancé
les quinze minutes c'est je fais comment
démarrer depuis qu'ils sont ainsi fait
râler vont bien
vichyssoise et tartare de thon servi
dans un cube de glace cutter
à 75 mètres d'altitude les plats
défilent
macaronis farcis au homard maury les
truffes
cochon de lait aux agrumes
et dessert
[Musique]
ces volets
à 23 heures le verdict tombe
roma a réalisé un sans faute
dans le centre ville john aussi aimerait
faire un sans faute
ce matin il a fait venir son associé au
garage ils doivent prendre une décision
importante
ensuite toujours le même concert on veut
s'agrandir un peu on veut pouvoir avoir
des groupes un peu plus grand cigare
dans l'esprit du
jazz et piotr ont décidé d'acheter 2
vannes d'occasions qu'ils vont
entièrement rénové
pour nous c'est un gros investissement
mais cela ne semble possible nous
connaissons bien le marché et je crois
qu'avec ses vannes nous allons proposer
quelque chose de vraiment nouveau
les vannes sont stationnés près du port
industriel
ils appartiennent à une société de
transports publics
est à mastaing tvn cancer ils sont
relativement bien conservé mais moteurs
sont bons on a vérifié
esthétiquement c'est une horreur absolue
on a une autre idée absurde au tas
il va donc falloir tout refaire
voici en baisse
dans l'os on va enlever tous les
revêtements qui les rideaux les tapis et
c'est pas la cérémonie en fait on va
souder aussi et refaire un autre entre
morts
au total zhao et piotr pas s'ils vont
investir 30000 euros
l'objectif est qu'il soit prêt pour la
fin de l'été
on se lance allez c'est parti
en attendant zhao part en direction de
la vieille ville il doit repérer un
itinéraire
spécialement conçu pour ses clients
français
on va marcher un peu on va s'arrêter
dans le born fait un tour dans le
quartier gothique
c'est le quartier le plus ancien de
barcelone
joão garcia motors à deux pas d'un
restaurant par itunes qui la connaît
bien
vois tu as bien et toi bien comme
d'habitude
ici il y a que des français
la manche à conques ou d'un ville de
mont saint michel à 4 ans à 80 km
on est là
c'est un village de 2500 habitants d une
douzaine d'ici on a fait notre lycée
ensemble on a été dans la cour de
récréation ensemble
à barr j'ai un autre copain car magasin
2e
m d'autres personnes qui sont installés
ici voilà chacun a fait sa vie à partir
c'est quoi cette presqu'île
c'est la pointe d'agon c'est une village
de l'envié en normandie à
l'epadesa
un petit coin de normandie que zhao a
décidé d'inclure dans son circuit pour
les touristes français
de l'autre côté de barcelone à gracia
nous retrouvons emmanuel dans sa
boutique de mobilier faits à partir de
matériaux recyclés
[Musique]
on va aller voir les décorations de la
rue verdi
à kayes est perdu
pour la première fois emmanuel participe
aux grands festivals de décoration de
rues de son quartier
un concours qui lui plaît
particulièrement car ici les riverains
n'ont le droit d'utiliser que des objets
recyclés
ça c'est un peu ce type papier mâché
comment commence taille comment vous
avez conçu les valeurs
race et du plastique
incroyable
bonjour colline en
colline et française salue
elle habite aussi quartier l'intérieur
ça des poils de balai
étoiles de beauval est
super
il est magnifique septembre
ces deux là
c'est une fête de voisins que ça prenne
des proportions comme ça c'est assez
incroyable c'est comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est comme une fête d'école
parce que tout le monde s'y met un peu
chacun selon son truc seulement le sait
x par sans quoi le l'impact
chaque rue choisi un thème
dans la calle verdi c'est le japon
un peu plus loin la france est à
l'honneur
alors on fait ça c'est un peu par et les
années 20 30 points oui alors également
il ya le moulin rouge hier on a
reproduit des choses stupides française
bon
alors ici c'est la clôture
avec l'écorcé on a
mal agi alors il fallait bien une petite
touche à pau libertines
soit fermé la rue san antoni et la
grande rivale de la rue où habitait
manuel est rien
une tour eiffel de 14 mètres de haut en
tulle de cartons on vient de verdi donc
j'étais impressionné mais là je me
demande si
i ils sont pas en train de marquer des
points dans cette ruche mais bon alors
en guerre
une douzaine de rues sont en compétition
il ne leur reste plus que quelques
minutes avant l'arrêt officiel des
travaux
le drapeau c'est le dernier ouais c'est
ça c'est à l'arrière jeu travail
la californie est prête juste à temps
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas tirs mais on est content et
on sait que on va pas se voir si on va
se revoir mais on mars version voilà les
prochaines étapes
et moi en fait
cette année la calle verdi a remporté le
premier prix
[Applaudissements]
pour fêter l'événement tous les
participants se retrouvent sur la grande
place de gracia
[Musique]
se suivent
septembre
une autre fête se prépare
au pied de la statue de la mercé la
sainte patronne de barcelone on a
c'est le grand jour
[Applaudissements]
et doit même les 250 cas steyer de la
peña de barcelone
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un jour de fête de
rencontres et de retrouvailles avec nos
amis et où tout le travail et
l'entraînement de ces derniers mois elle
a porté ses fruits sur ces places
chaque trou chaque peña porte fièrement
ses couleurs
edwards et salvin sont en rouge et blanc
les peña concurrentes porte le vert ou
le mot
on va réaliser une figure de neuf étages
plus de 200 personnes vont y participer
et on ne peut pas inscrire tous les noms
sur le schéma mais on sera plus de 200
les peña se mesure sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville
[Musique]
moi j'ai montré voilà même cette
direction alors moi je garde aussi mais
tu as et a fait il ya beaucoup de monde
mais après troisième étage
aujourd'hui les quais steyer de
barcelone vont tenter l'exploit
le rôle de chacun est essentielle
[Musique]
une erreur
une faiblesse
[Musique]
et c'est tout l'édifice qui s'écroule
au sommet lila culmine à plus de dix
mètres de hauteur
[Applaudissements]
la chute est spectaculaire
mais heureusement elle est amorti par
les centaines de corps qui forment la
base de la pyramide
[Applaudissements]
c'est les tâches duo qui s'est déformée
et du coup la pyramide s'est effondré
c'est une jeune castet hier au cinquième
niveau qui a sévi
[Applaudissements]
la chute heureusement n'a fait que des
blessés légers
[Musique]
sur la place
une autre peña s'élance
et réussi sa pyramide
[Musique]
à
les castes et fière de barcelone
galvanisés
se remettent en position
et forme une base compact
il faut être précis si les dimensions ne
sont pas corrects dès le début il vaut
mieux tout démonter avant que les étages
supérieurs ne deviennent instables donc
on va s'appliquer pour iag
il
m
le cast est fière de barcelone
galvanisés
se remettent en position
une basque
[Musique]
il sert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'édifice tient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ça revient dans ce cas céline on a
réussi cette figure que trois fois dans
le passé trois fois seulement en 45 ans
aujourd'hui c'est la quatrième alors on
est vraiment super heureux
[Applaudissements]
la joie est immense
et pour toutes ces familles c'est la
plus belle des récompenses
[Musique]
à barcelone les fêtes s'enchaînent mais
il ya un soir où tout ça aide ces soirs
de match ce soit romain ne travaille
donc pas il emmène des amis venus de
france
voir le spectacle dont toute la ville
pas
c'est ce que tu fais vas-y toi et tu
prends françois à l'avenir palace
je vais montrer
ils ont tous rendez vous au camp nou le
temple du football catalan le barça
rencontres le paris saint germain
[Musique]
c'est josé un ami de roman qui invite
tous ne
dis pas ça pour lui les places ne sont
pas un problème
mon grand père était président du barça
a été au tour de mon père
c'est une histoire de
fonnière
à barcelone le barça c'est bien plus
qu'un club de foot
parmi les spectateurs on retrouve salvat
le cast est fière de barcelone il n'aura
jamais un match
j'aimerais juste avant
le barça et la catalogne ont toujours
été très unis pendant la dictature de
franco il était interdit par le catalan
sauf dans ce stade
au stade salvan à sa place à l'année
on va entrer par la porte de droite
c'est par là
le quand nous c'est le plus grand stade
d'europe
il peut accueillir cent mille supporters
et
[Musique]
ce soir il faut qu'on gagne
on n'a pas le choix faut gagner ce match
[Applaudissements]
romain et ses amis sont de l'autre côté
du stable
à l'entrée des vip
[Musique]
là ce sont les noms de ma grand-mère au
grand père ma grand mère maternelle ma
soeur ma main r mais deux autres soeurs
mon oncle ma tante et enfin mes deux
cousins
[Musique]
dans sa loge
josé a tout juste eu le temps de
présenter le joueur du barça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est iniesta et neymar
déjà le premier but pour le psg
on fait comment
quant à marion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les gradins salvat temps énervé
les salles du repas
[Applaudissements]
m
le barça
l'emportent 3
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain matin romain et oscar vont
au marché de la boqueria
il y a huit mois il entamer les travaux
pour ouvrir un comptoir de sandwichs
cuisiner mais tout s'est pas passé comme
prévu
on s'est trompé au départ on a voulu
monter un endroit de saint maulvis
nomades comme on avait expliqué et en
même temps il ya eu le voisin qui a eu
la même idée donc il a monté ça bien
mais ça marchait pas non comme l'indiqué
son affaire on va pas se lancer dans
quelque chose qui fonctionne pas on a
réorienté le business parce que des fois
on se défendre pour se tromper des fois
les choses ne sont pas ce qu'on pensait
qu'elle serait maintenant les sur
quelque chose de très très populaire sa
pizza et de su animer les produits du
marché
les deux hommes ont le sens du business
aujourd'hui leur affaire est un succès
et l'autre 24 aura s'il vous plaît
plus d'une centaine de pizzas sont
vendus chaque jour
et grâce aux relations d'oscar
romain a une nouvelle idée
[Musique]
alors là c'est le nouvel endroit si vous
voulez c'est en fait ces deux locaux qui
sont complètement jumeaux en fait
qu'est-ce que c'est la même taille même
au même endroit et là on passe de se
faire des pizzas à faire les huîtres et
sa part à une rencontre on fait ça en
fait on fait des huîtres avec avec joël
dupuch c'est le producteur d'huîtres qui
sur le bassin d'arcachon vous avez déjà
dû voir dans le film les petits
mouchoirs c'est la chaîne de l'amitié
non mais c'est de monter des affaires et
de le faire avec des amis et est donc là
on a trouvé cet endroit pour faire les
huîtres
dans leur nouveau projet on a le romain
et oscar aussi mettre en valeur les
produits que l'on trouve sur la grille
du vieux port entre les yachts de
milliardaires
les barques de pêcheurs
a barcelone il ne reste qu'une douzaine
de bateaux de poche son actif
ouais c'est vrai
au printemps c'est la saison des gambas
et des langoustes
on
commença à 5 heures du matin ils ont
passé toute la journée en mer et ramène
ses crevettes et septembre
ce matin les pêcheurs sont d'humeur
taquine
tu dois manger nos crevettes crues sinon
tu n'es pas un vrai chef
allez bon appétit
c'est l'épreuve du feu je venais manger
l'épreuve du feu
ils sont vraiment incroyables
le gamba ce rouge de barcelone sont très
recherchés elles sont immédiatement
vendu à la criée du port
alors ils vont poser les casiers de
poisson ici puis les étiqueter ça va
défiler sur le tapis roulant que les
acheteurs puissent les voir et enchérir
à la base pour part toujours du prix le
plus haut et en dessin peut toujours
comme ça
tous les acheteurs des restaurants sont
déjà là et les prix sont plutôt et de
bon sens
oscar et romain parviennent à acheter
deux caisses de gambas
en baisse aujourd'hui on va les cuisines
et salles uniquement à la police
aujourd'hui romain et oscar ont une
autre mission
ils veulent sélectionner pour le bar des
vins blancs de la région pour rendre le
moment plus agréable ils ont fait appel
à john
il vient tout juste de finir la
restauration d'un des deux vannes acheté
il ya six mois
bonjour comment ça va
aulas c'est du
pin tueur vernis
toit ouvrant en six mois
l'écart aussi ont fait du bon travail
avec son van joâo peut maintenant
proposer des destinations touristiques
plus lointaines
[Musique]
nous allons dans une région au nord de
barcelone à une demi heure ça s'appelle
les ja et on y trouve une grande
tradition viticole qui date de l'époque
romaine
les vignes se situe à flanc de colline
juste au dessus de la mer
on entre dans la propriété
ainsi il n'y a pratiquement que de la
vigne
alors
3 ma compagne
cros et maria a créé le domaine il ya
vingt ans
entre amateurs de bonnes choses le
courant passe tout de suite
et le procès de català ah
rendimiento
elle est en train de finir
près goûter un tranquillement
il y allons en disant qu'on a démarré à
travailler sans soja
pour mieux apprécier ces vins organique
romain veinards se met aux fourneaux
c'est poil et à la fleur d'ail
ventrèche confites à la plancha
gamba ce rouge à la croûte de sel
c'est parfait le sel a bien fait son
travail
hahaha
les cuisiniers sont satisfaits a été
démolie moval à l'eia c'est la plus
petite appellation viticole d'espagne
elle est située dans un parc naturel
protégé
d'ici on voit tout barcelone le montant
bien beau la tour agbar sagrada familia
la sagrada familia justement a encore
changé
les tailleurs de pierre ont relevé leurs
défis
fait liu et ses compagnons
ont terminé en 3 mois
leur lettre j'ai un
pouvoir tailler ses pierres et ensuite
les placer sur cet édifice emblématique
c'est une véritable fierté
fenioux et les 300 artisans qui
travaillent avec lui se sont tous
engagés à avoir terminé la sagrada dans
dix ans
tout juste cent ans après la mort
d'anthony gueule
[Musique]